[Musique]
ce qui s'annonçait comme une mission
plutôt tranquille s'est transformée en
affrontements violents avec l'ennemi au
sud ouest de kandahar
les militaires et notre équipe ont tenté
de franchir une montagne jusqu'à ce
qu'il saute sur une mine
c'est la preuve qu'on est absolument à
l'abri de rien dans ce pays
avoir su s'arrêter une opération si
dangereuse on serait pas allé et c'est
ce faux sentiment de sécurité qu'on a
acquis depuis quelques temps qui
viennent de disparaître aujourd'hui
quand on est au cabaret du capitole vous
voyez cette scène derrière moi où va se
produire le couronnement de pauline
marois ce soir je suis formellement chef
du parti qui n'est qu'en 2007 c'est
l'année de pauline marois
le tueur en série robert pickton a été
reconnu coupable des meurtres non
prémédités de six femmes du quartier
downtown eastside de vancouver
le coupable pourrait néanmoins
bénéficier d'une remise de peine
d'ici une dizaine d'années il ya
évidemment la disparition d'un enfant à
trois rivières est cédrika provencher
qui a 9 ans est introuvable
la bicyclette de la jeune fille a été
retrouvée à moins de deux kilomètres au
sud de ce quartier résidentiel d'où elle
a été vue pour la dernière fois
savait que sa vie était en danger
pourtant benazir bhutto a décidé de
retourner chez elle il ya deux mois et
elle a été assassiné ce matin en pleine
campagne électorale en vue des élections
du 8 janvier
à 52 ans nicolas sarkozy devient le
sixième président de la vème république
nicolas sarkozy dit vouloir rassembler
une france qui s'est scindé en deux
depuis des mois partout où il va il
attire les foules
huit mille personnes ont rempli les
gradins de cet aréna pour venir entendre
le message du dalaï lama après le
macintosh en 1984
le imac en 1998 à paul frappe encore
l'imagination des technophiles en
lançant vendredi son iphone
[Musique]